hiya Steve Kaufman here last day in
Spain I hope the wind doesn't kick up
too much here and disrupt the sound like
it did the last time it is my last day
in Spain so I want to talk about
learning Spanish perhaps giving you some
of my views on things to consider when
you think of learning Spanish first of
all it's a great language to learn
because there are so many speakers I
don't know what the number is half
million or more and it opens up the
whole world of Romance languages French
Italian Portuguese Catalan we're in
Catalonia here romanian so you know some
people say well you should learn Latin
or you should learn interlingua
as an introduction or a sort of a
neutrals Latin or Romance language but
Spain does the job Spanish right so it's
a big lot of native speakers it opens
the door to Romance languages and there
are so many resources available there
are telenovelas from Mexico from Spain
in other words Netflix movies there are
movies there are books there's
literature there's so much stuff to get
into songs music you know we're all
familiar with songs from Latin America
from Spain so it's a great language to
get into because there's a lot of
material that can be used for learning
so when we look at learning Spanish some
people get a little intimidated because
they say I can't roll my arse like this
bad dude
are they sir aware that in Spanish there
are two words for to be said and it's
Tata
Sayre which is a more permanent state of
being and a star which is a more
transitory for temporary state of being
all very well and good when you explain
it very difficult to remember to do when
you're speaking because of course we
don't do that
at least we don't do it in English so
anything that another language has that
we don't have in our language regardless
of the explanations you get is going to
very be very difficult to get to develop
the habit to do people are aware that
you know you don't need to always use
the pronouns because the verbs change so
you know boy you know that I go because
boy is aij oh boy you don't say Jo boy
so there are a few things like that what
else would there be is that a star I
mean oh yes and the subjunctive that
people worry about you know because
again in English we've more or less lost
this identity none of that matters none
of that matters because oh well yeah
none of that matters because of several
reasons first of all I would say if you
you want to learn Spanish your goal
should be to understand movies to
understand the telenovelas and do them
from Mexico from Argentina from Colombia
from Spain it doesn't matter the
differences are not that great despite
what people say get usually have it as
your goal to be able to understand these
that should be a strategy so it's a
six-month or a one-year strategy you
want to get to where you understand
those and you understand songs and you
can even read a book so those should be
the goals not I want to be able to
pronounce the Spanish a literate are
that'll come don't worry about it up
front I want to nail down saternus done
don't worry about it it won't prevent
you from understanding if you build up
sufficient familiarity with the language
vocabulary to where you can understand
the movies and telenovelas on Netflix
you'll be on your way so that should be
the goal now how do you get there well I
would recommend a course as you know I
would because of my experience with our
many stories at link which I have used
now for five languages
I would attack the many stories and link
and we have only 20 in European Spanish
we have 60 and Latin American Spanish we
are getting the other 40 in Latin
American Spanish I would do both
versions so that and I would end up
listening to them 20 30 40 times not all
at once
but as you progress through them and you
go back and review them again and just
do the many stories and make it a point
to say within three months you're gonna
get through all 60 mini stories once
that's done you now have sufficient
vocabulary to start attempting you know
stuff that you can find on YouTube
movies or Netflix you can use the hour
you know browser extension to bring
material in from YouTube and Netflix and
to study and I've mentioned this before
you would go into a Netflix movie and
set the subtitles to Spanish and then
import that into link whereas if you are
watching on TV you may leave the
subtitles in English so that you have a
better chance of understanding the
movies but the goal is to get to where
you can enjoy and understand the movies
Netflix telenovelas the whole thing
because if you achieve that level of
understanding in the language the
speaking will come and to try to sort of
nail down you know I would like a beer
I'd like to make a reservation for a
table this evening at the restaurant
it's very hard to do because you might
memorize those then you go to say those
things and then they answer something
that you weren't anticipating and now
you're lost so you go back to English so
the idea that you can just come up with
some kind of
set phrases a few set phrases that are
gonna do it for you I mean that's that's
an approach but since it's Steve's tips
to learning Spanish I don't recommend
that I recommend that you set as your
goal to understand Spanish movies and
you have a strategy to get there and
even to read a book or to listen to an
audiobook all of these things you can
bring in to link so you elevate your
level of familiarity and your vocabulary
at which and there you don't have to
worry about certain estar you don't have
to worry about
trilling your R's because you're just
absorbing the language but you are
getting the brain used to those sounds
you're getting the brain used to those
structures so that at some point when
you decide now I want to try to use it
you will be dealing from a position of
strength and you know when it comes to
the subjunctive you know if you come
across it and you're not sure what the
form is I mean now there's so many good
dictionaries like that link we have
conjugating dictionaries whether it be
context Reverso or there's another
conjugating dictionary so anytime you
come across a verb you just look it up
and you see what it is you don't try to
remember it but at least you're you're
made aware that there are all these
ranges there's different endings that
you're in the come across gradually
accumulating this experience so it's
become a stress free way of building up
your overall level of competence in
Spanish for all the good reasons that I
said at the beginning so while I've been
here I've been interviewed in Spanish
press by radio by television and I'm
gonna leave some links in the
description box to some of these
interviews that I've had and again my
approach to Spanish has always been to
focus on comprehension and of course
whenever we get the opportunity to speak
we speak now you don't worry about
setting estar and we don't worry about
rolling our arse we just speak and just
let it come out the way it comes out
because in time it will only get better
so those are and you know I'm leaving
Spain with great regret we are gonna
have Catalan in link we're working right
now on enriching the material will have
a Catalan
and I think at some point I'm gonna
learn Catalan and it is six seven
million people who speak Catalan so it's
not an insignificant language and it's
just another one of the Romance
languages that learning Spanish is gonna
make it easier for you to learn along
with Italian and Portuguese and Romanian
and French so I thank you for listening
and good luck with your Spanish bye for
now
[Music]